[Musique]
direction le pavillon d'armenonville à
paris
c'est ici que se tiennent les rencontres
de l'internationalisation des
collectivités territoriales et dans la
salle bagatelle
on retrouve les représentants des
comores venu signer un accord de
coopération et des échanges avec les
collectivités de dunkerque de
seine-saint-denis de la courneuve
d'anjou et le département de la réunion
en est venu aux insinuations des
impressions capacités mais aussi paul
d'apport sourire la retraite
le cru 2 par rapport à la gouvernance un
protocole d'accord au pluriel expliqué
en détail par la présidente du
département
il ya trois mois nous étions comeau pour
représenter la france et nous avions
avec nous tous les représentants de la
coopération décentralisée par exemple
l'amérique courneuve ou bien la
communauté d'agglomération de dunkerque
ou encore le département de seine saint
denis
chaque collectivité à des projets avec
l'état comorien ou les associations pour
aider les gens dans l'éducation dans la
santé dans l'agriculture dans la
problématique de l'eau la gestion de
l'eau ya pas y'a pas de haut komo est
vide et a été de se dire que nous
pourrions coordonner nos actions les
mutualiser pour essayer d'apporter les
meilleures réponses les grands défis que
les comores ont relevé pour les
prochaines années
première signature donc aujourd'hui
trois mois après nous signons une
convention avec unifrance pour que au
niveau de toutes les collectivités de
l'hexagone comme de l'outre-mer à la
réunion de puissions travailler ensemble
et mettre nos efforts en commun avec le
ministère des affaires étrangères et
puis cet après midi en présence deux des
trois gouverneurs des îles des comores
et nous avons également signé un projet
avec le ministère de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères pour avoir une
représentation de ce ministère à la
réunion qui serait coordonné par le
préfet au nom de l'état français et puis
il y avait cette après midi également
les associations des mairies
associations des maires des comores
puisque pour la première fois de son
histoire les comores ont élu il y a un
an et demi démocratiquement 54 nayve
dont quatre femmes et donc avec le cnfpt
le département de la réunion nous
apportons une formation à tous ses élus
une formation qui permettra à l'avenir
une meilleure coopération entre les
comores et les collectivités françaises
[Musique]